[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily a verdict in the
trial of a fake pizza delivery order
did this woman get away with murder for
seven years
and the case into the death and
disappearance of a missing mother
continues on
why the defense for one of the suspects
wants the trial moved to a different
county
plus the family of a 12-year-old boy
killed by the police
wants to know why the federal
prosecutors closed the case
before reviewing the evidence law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the family of a 12-year-old boy shot and
killed by the police
is asking federal authorities to reopen
the case
anjanet levy explains why the family was
shocked to learn
it was closed before the investigation
even began
yeah brian you may recall that back in
2014
a police officer in cleveland shot and
killed tamir rice tamir was only 12
years old and a security camera
captured the entire incident tamir was
in a park
and had to had a pellet gun that looked
like a real gun when he was shot
the officer shot him within two seconds
of arriving after receiving a 9-1-1 call
about someone in the park with a gun the
boy's family and
attorneys have pushed for a justice
department investigation
sabode chandra represents the rice
family
he sent a letter to the doj after the
new york times and the washington post
reported the investigations the family
had requested
ended when career prosecutors asked to
convene a grand jury
and were denied you know the career
prosecutors quit their jobs that's
apparently how
strongly they felt about the political
interference they left
the department of justice so our hope is
the next administration will also reach
out to them to do a complete
and impartial investigation of the
political interference that has
apparently occurred here
i've contacted the department of justice
for a comment on sabode chandra's letter
and the status of the investigation into
tamir rice's death
i have not yet received a response brian
angina is the rice family also asking
for documents related to the case
yeah brian you know they're asking for a
number of documents related to this case
they're hoping to glean
any new information from those documents
specifically they want to see a
whistleblower complaint
that was filed with the inspector
general's office
we are told by sabah sabode chandra that
that in that complaint was not
investigated by the inspector general
instead it was handed over to a
department that has
a narrowest scope in investigating
complaints
thanks aunt jeanette there seems to be
two issues
here interference with the the case and
the violation of federal laws
joining us now is julie renneman
criminal defense attorney to help break
down
this case along with terry austin terry
let's start with you
federal laws provide certain rights to
victims
if the family is right here and these
were violated what remedy if any do they
have
well you know brian under federal law
there is no legal recourse for the
family the government
is supposed to provide the victim with
information about the process
like you know whether or not they there
is probation or whatever the
system may have as far as the victim is
concerned
but the law doesn't create a cause of
action
against the government if they fail to
provide information
as required by law so they really are
stuck if they don't get the information
that they're trying to request here
yeah that seems pretty difficult julie
like anjanette said the family is asking
for a lot of documents here
what do you think their chances of
success are and could that change with a
new administration
yeah so you know look you know i agree
with terry i think that
the one thing they have going for them
is the change in administration there
was always talk that this
there was you know politics that seemed
to surround every case that gets
national attention such as this one and
so one does wonder
if um when the administration changes
that perhaps they'll have a better shot
at getting some of the
the information they want that's not
necessarily going to bring them to where
they want to be in terms of what they
view as justice
but at least will give them some
additional information that they can
glean
you know something in regards to what
happened and of course if they do get
more information julie could this
kind of help the ball move forward and
maybe there will be some sort of case
it could i mean you know look we always
have to compare these cases and the
facts of this case to other
uh cases involving you know police
officer
brutality um and you know there are
certain aspects that seem to support the
police officer's position we don't know
however if there's not going to be
and if there is additional evidence out
there that may corroborate or help
the victim in this case i will make sure
to keep an eye on the rice case and the
family as they look for more information
there's a shocking new claim by
prosecutors in california
terry austin has more brian these
prosecutors say
scams in pandemic unemployment benefits
led to millions of dollars going to
convicted murderers
like scott peterson the sacramento
county district attorney says an
investigation discovered
more than 140 million paid to inmates
across the states
in 38 prisons another 400 thousand was
paid to death row inmates
like carrie steiner convicted of killing
four people and peterson who was
convicted of killing his wife and
unborn son peterson's attorney denies
his involvement
and in florida the case of the employee
of a publix supermarket is suing after
they say
their loved one died from coronavirus
attorneys for the family of
70 year old grotto guterres
say he died in april after contracting
covet 19 from a co-worker
the lawsuit alleges publix management
initially refused to allow employees to
wear masks
and gloves and the gear which would
scare off the customers they said the
lawsuit is seeking damages in
excess of thirty thousand dollars wow
a death because of uh not wanting to
wear mass out of fear of scaring away
customers well
thanks terry in a major development in
the opioid crisis
the maker of the medication oxycontin
pled oxycodone sorry pled guilty to
federal charges of three conspiracy
criminal charges
purdue pharma also agreed to a more than
eight billion dollar settlement
where the company would be remade to a
public benefit company
prosecutors said the company played a
major role
in the opioid epidemic chairman steve
miller appeared in court and pled guilty
on behalf of the company
still ahead on law and crime daily the
investigation into a missing mother in
connecticut is continuing as her
deceased husband's girlfriend
appears in court and later why fleeing
from court may not be such a good idea
one woman's dash from a bailiff out to
the parking lot and into our own car
when we return
back the defense of a suspect in the
case of a missing connecticut mother
is trying to get the trial moved to a
different county
michelle troconis is accused of playing
a role in the alleged murder
of jennifer dulos dulos's body has never
been found
her estranged husband photos dullos was
charged in her disappearance as well
but he died in an apparent suicide
earlier this year
he was dating troconis at the time and
investigators say surveillance video
shows them disposing of evidence
her attorneys want her trial moved to a
county where the evidence was recovered
not the alleged crime scene a request
prosecutors say
has no merit council's argument
that jurors should be selected from
hartford
when the state's allegation is that the
defendant
conspired to kill a new canaan resident
who was then killed in new canaan
but the jurors should come from hartford
i i think is
is a little ill advised as far as
arguments go
we're not saying uh mr conas literally
stands
in uh fotus dulos's place
but that her liability is the same as
head
should the jury decide to find her
guilty under that
theory which they have two choices one
is to find her guilty as a principal and
one
as an accessory but were they to find
her guilty as an accessory
where that theory is an option again
relying on my uh our submission to the
court
it is the case in many jurisdictions and
i would submit should be the case in
connecticut
that accessories to crimes can expect to
be tried and should expect to be tried
and are triable
in not only were they rendered criminal
assistance but where the principal
committed the act
of the crime the defense's requests are
going even further
they want to know where are the photos
the police took of troconis
during a strip search they strip
searched my client
under the statue it does say they need
an order from either the chief of police
or a designated supervisor to even
authorize that
the fact that the court signed a search
warrant allowing
photographs of mission uh mr conas's
body
did not say anything about a strip
search the statutes are clear
i want to see that that was even done
number one number two those pictures are
missing they're not listed as evidence
they're not stored anyway i don't know
there's
nothing has been disclosed about where
those photographs
ended up there's a state police mail
officer wrote a description of each of
the
25 or 30. i don't have that report in
front of me
photographs so he stood there and
looked at these pictures of my client
seminude
and then wrote a description of each one
i don't know where these pictures are i
don't know if they were even
uh in a in a protected area for all i
know
they were passed around the state police
barracks and true l
and have been since i have had no
information what happened
to them there was some strong
allegations terry we know that discovery
requests can often be a slugfest between
two sides
but in this case is this just two sides
squabbling over nothing
or is this just how we get to proper
disclosures you know this defense
counsel is relatively new on the case
and he's asking for everything and the
kitchen sink he's asking for the autopsy
report
of photos dulos he's asking for these
pictures of the strip search why he's
doing that i have no idea
he wants a custody report for the
doulo's divorce and you know he's asking
for a manuscript that jennifer deulos
wrote that wasn't published
it's odd to me i don't think any of this
is going to be exculpatory as far as
michelle draconis is concerned but it
will absolutely be
extremely interesting if he in fact gets
all of this information
interesting is it's quite the word to
use i i would use it as well
julie this change of venue argument
sometimes sounds more like the defense
is saying
they're in the wrong jurisdiction
altogether what do you make of the
defense's argument
yeah it seems like there's some
confusion even for the prosecution when
they hear the defense's argument as to
whether they're talking about
venue or jurisdiction jurisdiction is
basically does the court have a right
to hear a case a venue is which court is
going to hear the case now it seems like
one of the issues they raise
is that there's publicity in one of the
venues so that they want the case moved
i understand that argument i'm not sure
it's going to hold water
the other argument is that you know the
evidence against draconis happened in
one place
and not in the other but i think it's
misguided because it really doesn't
matter where
draconis's act happened it matters where
other pieces of the evidence and pieces
of the crime happen and so
the case can be tried in each of those
jurisdictions
yeah and again we're not talking like
moving from one state to another this is
one county to another
within the state of connecticut we'll
definitely keep eyes on that to see how
that plays out
there's a verdict in a murder trial
we've been following right here on law
and crime daily
we'll take you inside the courtroom
where jurors announce their decision
plus a defendant makes a quick escape
during her sentencing hearing
how u.s marshals caught up with his
fleeing felon after the break
[Music]
good you're back so and 180 days in jail
might
seem like a light sentence but to one
woman it was more than she bargained for
law and crime founder and host of the a
e network's court camp
dan abrams has the video
first we go to the berea municipal court
in berea ohio
the sentencing hearing of 42 year old
stephanie ripkowski
rukovsky was caught stealing from a
local walmart which resulted in a theft
conviction
today she and her attorney are hoping
judge mark comstock
doesn't issue any jail time
first of all 150 dollar fine plus cost
but that's suspended
and then 180 days in jail i'll credit
one day serve however
i will start that today
six months in jail starting today is not
the outcome rukovsky was looking for
so she quickly appeals to the judge
that i can not start jail today i mean
because i've got a daughter we've got a
graduation party going on at home
i understand i understand that and we're
going to stick with the recommendation
at this point
so again you can have a seat command
from the table
absolutely you'll be able to use it
disappointed ribcoski goes to take her
seat
until she changes her mind and heads for
the door
bailiff matthew bedford takes notice and
immediately tells him
he catches up to her in the hallway
where they have a discussion
ripkoski bides her time by taking a seat
she then checks her phone while the
bailiff waits her out and
stands guard at the staircase
acting casual she wanders over to the
bailiff while on the phone
and then slips behind him
until she makes a break for it
she quickly makes her way down two
flights of stairs and out the front
doors
with the bailiff right behind her
[Music]
eventually she gets to her car and
knocks the bailiff over with the vehicle
before speeding away
luckily he suffers only minor injuries
but finding her wasn't easy it would
take 11 days before she was finally
caught
and arrested and this time she's hit
with additional charges of escape
assault
and resisting arrest but no additional
jail time is added to her original
sentence
wow season three of court cam is out now
on the a
e networks and when we come back who
placed the fake pizza order that lured
an army veteran to her death
a verdict in the murder trial of an ohio
woman implicated by her ex-husband
stay with us for capital gavel coverage
the jury has found the defendant erica
stefanko guilty
of the offense of aggravated murder the
jury has found the defendant erica
stefanko not guilty
of the offense of aggravated murder the
jury has found the defendant erica
stefanko not guilty of the offense of
kidnapping
the jury has found the defendant erica
stefanko not guilty
of the offense of aggravated robbery
a mixed verdict in the murder trial of
an ohio woman accused of helping to kill
her husband's ex-girlfriend
jurors found erica stefanko guilty of
murder but not guilty of kidnapping and
robbery
therefore finding her not guilty of one
of the murder charges
prosecutors say stefanco placed a fake
pizza order at domino's to lure ashley
biggs to her death
biggs was a retired army veteran and
worked as a delivery driver
stefanko's ex-husband chad cobb pled
guilty to murdering biggs
and helped to implicate stefanko police
discovered the victim's body
after a neighbor spotted her car in a
cornfield
the individual's face was very dark
purple
i can still picture that
there were taser wires coming off of
the individual
she had on a domino's shirt
tan shorts a leather belt white tennis
shoes
there were zip ties around her hands or
wrists
and what appeared to be zip tie
around her neck there was also
blood around her on the
i want to say on the floor but i don't
remember exactly where the blood was
and then at that point i contacted my
captain just hours before reaching their
verdict it appeared the jury had been
deadlocked
then the judge instructed the jury to
resume deliberations
the court has been advised that you have
indicated difficulty
in reaching a verdict the court requests
that you make every reasonable effort to
agree on a verdict
there is no reason to support that the
case will ever be submitted to 12
individuals more intelligent more
impartial
or more competent to decide it or that
additional evidence will be produced by
either side
it is your duty to make every reasonable
effort
to decide the case if you can
conscientiously do so
in court the jury asked to hear back
this recording cobb's mother made
of the defendant allegedly confessing to
her involvement
[Applause]
[Applause]
and it wasn't because it was forcing me
to do it or like he had a gun in my head
it was because he said this is your
partner this is what you're going to do
which is how it always was what you
should see what we're supposed to do
um
all right it's a mixed verdict do you
think the jury got it right here
i do think they got it right brian
because look they
know she was guilty of murder but there
was no evidence saying that she was
involved in the kidnapping or the
robbery
and so i think it was a compromise you
heard the judge there do the allen
charge because they couldn't reach a
decision
so i think what they decided to do here
was to split the decision so i think it
was
actually the right decision at the end
of the day julie mixed verdicts are
interesting because it shows the jury
believes some of the charge but not
others when you step back and look at
the case as a whole
does it make sense to you absolutely you
know
we talk about a split verdict but at the
end of the day um
she was found guilty of aggravated
murder which is the top count
the exact count that chad cobb pled
guilty to
um the fact that they didn't find her
guilty of the underlying felonies
is not surprising because there was very
very little evidence at you know as
terry was pointing out
that referred or or could have
established in any way that she was
involved in the kidnapping aspect of
this case
so it's not a surprise that they instead
went with the premeditation
all right so possible sentence terry
what are you thinking here
does she get more than chad cobb or the
same
i don't think she's going to get more
you know i think they did not go for the
death penalty here so
you know she could get a range of years
here and hopefully since she was
involved in the murder
i'm hoping that it's a large amount of
years all right
julie terry thank you very much and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you